des migrants qui survivent dans le froid
et la neige depuis l' incendie qui a
ravagé le camp de l'ipa le 23 décembre
dernier plus d'un millier d'entre eux
sont livrés à la précarité dans le nord
ouest de la bosnie
l'union européenne a décidé ce dimanche
de débloquer 3,5 millions d'euros
supplémentaires d'assistance humanitaire
pour les réfugiés et migrants dans le
pays
dans son communiqué le chef de la
diplomatie européenne josep borrell
dénonce des conditions inhumaines
la situation est inacceptable un
hébergement adapté à l'hiver est
indispensable pour des conditions de
vies humaines qui doivent être garantis
à tout moment les autorités locales
doivent mettre à disposition leurs
structures existantes disponibles et
fournir une solution temporaire
d'hébergement en attendant que le camp
l'ipa soit reconstruit en une
infrastructure permanente
une situation d'autant plus inquiétante
avec les conditions météo extrêmes et
une autre menace ajoute celle du
coronavirus locaux vides 19 s'est
répandue ici un campement temporaire
pendant la pandémie de kobe de 19
ce n'est pas un lieu éligibles pour les
personnes vivant en hiver les voir la
situation ici
la température est en baisse négative et
le temps et glacial
nous ne voulons pas vivre ici est
déménagée dans les tentes parce que dans
cette situation
par ce temps le camp ne peut pas être
capable de vivre ici un appel à l'aide
qui tarde à se faire entendre du côté
des autorités locales
la classe politique bosnienne est
divisée face à la réponse à donner à la
crise migratoire entre pouvoir local et
pouvoir fédéral les autorités de bihac
se sont opposé à la réouverture d'un
centre dans le centre ville
en attendant ils survivent depuis
vendredi dans ces tentes installées par
les forces armées du pays
la bosnie accueille aujourd'hui quelques
8000 migrants qui restent bloqués aux
portes de l'europe